pour que la cuisine soit bonne il faut
des oignons dedans autrement c'est de la
cuisine de techno
[Rires]
Charlesbourg fils agriculteur en
retraite s'est marié en rillettes le 3
novembre 1945 dans son village 15 roues
à quelques kilomètres de Montbard il y
avait alors cette ferme aujourd'hui il
reste Charles et Henriette de la bonne
humeur du bon sens un regard sur le
passé une vision de l'avenir et puis
déjà 20 ans de retraite comme je suis
beaucoup fatigué j'aime mieux être en
tête que d'être en activité le matin je
me lève le plus tard possible pour que
la journée soit le moins longue possible
né en 1915 Charles a toujours été proche
de la nature il a même quelques secrets
de longévité
il est parti
dernièrement là sur le tilleul de 15 €
qui est meilleur que celui-ci à la
pharmacie et puis l'hiver avec une
camomille dedans la camomille qu'on
fabriquait mais comme la fiscalité nous
a réduit en public
et bien on peut plus mettre de camomille
dans le tilleul
parce que ça se dit-il la camomille
il apporte bien saisi le monsieur hein
ça rallume l'organisme et puis ça le
fait aller plus loin dans la vie
lorsqu'ils étaient en activité les beaux
fils élevaient une vingtaine de bêtes et
cultivait 40 hectares de terre
aujourd'hui il leur reste un grand
jardin ici ça va être l'avenir de la
salade chicorée scarole il faut pas
s'employer à quelque chose si on veut
rester
actif autrement pour que la cuisine soit
bonne il faut des oignons dedans
autrement c'est de la cuisine de techno
[Rires]
et puis les enfants il y a eu trois
enfants alors ils viennent
c'est pas la vie ça
[Musique]
ici on se repose des fois on se réveille
mais
quand on a de l'occupant et ben ça ne
limite pas là-dedans parce qu'on
s'occupe peut-être quelque chose mais
quand on a rien à faire et ben on dit
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire allez on place
les jambes sont en couple et on s'en va
jusqu'à Saint-Germain
et puis on discute du passé du présent
et du futur on a passé un moment de la
vie qui a eu une grande évolution en
tout et pour tout et puis souhaite qu'il
y en ait encore pour les générations
futures mais ils auront des obstacles à
surmonter
quand la nuit s'approche les beaux fils
quittent leur salon pour se rendre à la
cuisine ici c'est chauffer au bois qu'un
stère par an comme au bon vieux temps et
puis Charles n'a jamais eu de tracteur
seulement trois chevaux de quoi
labourrer un journal 34 dans sa journée
[Musique]
moi j'ai pas de permis de conduire
et non
de toute façon Charles n'a jamais aimé
les moteurs
le gars ce qu'il a ce que j'aime pas ça
me gêne le battement
Henriette elle a fait deux grands
voyages deux journées passées à Dijon et
l'an 2000 ne va pas bouleverser son mode
de vie
de bonnes choses pour la société
française mais il va y avoir des
restrictions le progrès il y a eu un
progrès monstre en tout domaine que ça
soit dans l'industrie que ça soit dans
n'importe quoi il y a eu beaucoup de
progrès mais ça a été trop vite parce
qu'on est au but
on n'est pas loin d'être au but alors
les autres puissances ils sont pas plus
couillons que nous
les Italiens ils vont fournir des
macaronias de frappes il est français
les fournissent à quatre francs ça y est
on est liquide depuis toujours les
beaux-fils mangent bio et ils le savent
Charles boisson va un peu acide coupé
avec de l'eau et surtout il va à la
pêche une passion propice à la réflexion
et à la méditation
il vient mais plus loin possible c'est
le meilleur
[Musique]